hello everyone and welcome to an
absolutely amazing game from day one of
the world blitz championship it's a java
christian
of uzbekistan versus shakir mahmud yarov
and it really seems uzbekistan is going
very strong in both the world rapid and
blitz championship uh this game features
the greatest opening chess
has ever known so uh be ready for that
and also sorry about showing you the
wrong standings in the previous video i
showed you the standings after 11 rounds
after this game we will also check out
the standings after uh around 12. so so
let's check out the game first and then
we're gonna enjoy the standing so
sindarov with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5 by mama yara of
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to c4
mamidarov goes for bishop to c5 we have
the joko piano and now uh you guys are
always wondering will it happen well
here it did happen here cinder played b4
the evans gambit is on the board and
what happened next uh surprised me even
more than uh him playing the evan's game
but mamadarov declines the gambit he
plays bishop to b6 and um in uh for
example in top tier tournaments in
you know a play where where good players
are playing there are about uh 3 000 and
some maybe 200 games in the database
where the pawn is accepted and there are
only about 500 games where the pawn is
declined so here uh it's questionable
why mamidyarov declines the uh the
sacrifice maybe he wants to confuse his
opponent maybe he has some greater
knowledge than we have that maybe
nowadays uh supercomputers have decided
that maybe bishop the b6 is better even
though our standard engines just say you
know captured upon or he never studied
the evan's gambit and he doesn't there
except the the b for pawn uh be that as
it may let's see what uh what happens
next we have a4
threatening a5 to trap the bishop while
still offering the b for pawn but
accepting the b4 pawn now uh would be
basically the same as accepting the
evan's gambit only white would get a
better position than in the original
acceptance of the eminence gambit if he
goes knight captures on b4 we play a5
and only after the bishop moves we get
c3 knight c6 and the d4 and you you are
basically playing the evan's gambit
accepted with um well some improvements
uh for white for example characters
captures bishop to be for check and
white can even play king to f1 you don't
even have to block this you can play
bishop d2 but you can also play king to
f1 and it's a really really tough
position to play for black how do you
develop this uh knight knight to f6 for
example can be met with e5 queen to b3
is coming all very nasty if you try d6
first to prevent e5 we play d5 and we
win the game on the spot so it's a
really really tough position to play you
can't capture here
uh because just queen to a4 check picks
up the bishop but the same applies if
you if you just move the knight queen a4
check picks up the bishop so uh it's not
uh possible to to accept the pawn now if
you wanted to accept the one you should
have done it uh
much much sooner so a six millimeter of
frees up the a7 square for the bishop
knight to c3 and now knight to f6 we
have castles and the d6 and mamirov is
very happy now he has his a6 bishop to
b6 d6 e5 setup and well no worry in the
world we have knight to d5 attacking the
bishop on b6 and monitor of trades here
we have captures captures attacking the
knight here and again uh the b4 pawn is
uh kind of being offered here but again
capturing it now just runs into a5 and
again
what do you do with the knight now once
you move the bishop
we can play some like bishop to a3 and
that's pretty much it there's not
nothing you can do there are no squares
available for this knight if you try
something like c5 then we just trap it
with c3 and again the the story repeats
itself so knight to d4 and now knight
captures on d for bishop captures on d4
and c3 uh we have bishop to a7 and now
d4 so white getting the the very
well-known setup we have castles by
black if you don't castle now you
probably never will uh d captures an e5d
captures and now yeah interestingly uh
and i i don't know how this is even
possible but uh uh cinderella uh played
the exact game wei yi already played
against mamadyarov uh in defeated world
cup 2013 that ended in a draw where we
played bishop to e3 but here cinder
improves with queen to e2 and it is now
only as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game so it's like he know
i mean of course you prepare for uh your
opponent to prepare openings but to know
the exact game and it's not like you
know that you're going to face mamidarov
in a tournament with 200 people so uh
cinderella knows uh many many games by
heart to be able to uh memorize this or
i i i would really be surprised if it
was a coincidence uh or maybe he just
had enough time to prepare this before
the actual round but either way it's
very very impressive so here attacking
the pawn this comes with a threat unlike
way is bishop to e3 and now queen to h4
you can't capture the pawn just yet
because the bishop on c4 would be
hanging so bishop to e3 and now bishop
to g4 attacking the queen so queen to a2
now the bishop is still defended so
black doesn't have any nasty discoveries
and now a5 uh striking at this b for
pawn but if you remember we are playing
the evan's gambit decline so white
shouldn't really have any problem giving
up the b for nc3 pawn because that's
what you kind of doing the evans gambit
accepted so here bishop captures an a7
rook captures and now a very impressive
f4 uh asking black what do you do here
uh white is threatening to pick up the
e5 pawn and have a massive pawn center
here if if you capture this for example
captures rook captures again a very
tough position for black the queen just
being here the queen bishop rook uh
attacking that f7 pawn the other rook is
coming to f1 black will not be able to
defend this so instead after f4 uh
mamidarov continues with a captures on
b4 uh we have f captures on e5 and now b
captures on c3 so yeah you know some 20
moves later uh mamadirov accepts the
evan's gambit uh and then now we have e6
uh beautiful play by by cinderella we
have bishop to h5 now defending the f7
square and now rook eight to e1 now
threatening to create a pass pawn here
and well you could just play something
like rook back to a8 and it seems like
the safest choice middle plays b5 it
seems like
all this pawn giving from white
convinced mama jarv that maybe he should
give up some pawns on the queen side as
well although there is no good reason to
do this it's it's a very odd move of
course the knight cannot capture so
cinderella captures with the bishop it
does get the bishop off of this diagonal
so that's probably why mamijarov did it
and now he even played c6 he gave up
another pawn uh which only allows
cinderella to create a past c pawn which
he does now we have f captures an e6 and
now queen captures an e6 with check we
have bishop to f7 the rooks are nicely
guarding the bishop here and now just
queen back to e3 and now if you look at
the position uh yes white is up a pawn
so uh he he played the evan's game but
mamiyarov declined it and then he sort
of accepted it later on in the game and
now it's mamidarov who was down the pawn
uh but not only that white has two pass
pawns here that are nicely defended by
the bishop so uh what can mahmoud do
here he plays rook c7 he stops the pawn
but now we have queen captures on c3 and
rook f the c8 now he will try to play
bishop to e8 and somehow win win at
least one of those pawns but rook to d1
it's a very important move you guard the
d4 square so you don't have to worry
about any queen d4 checks in the future
also rook lifts with rook to d6 are
possible if white if black really goes
after that c6 pawn so bishop to e8 and
now queen to b3 with check here mamadar
blocks with bishop to e7 attacks the
queen and now feel free to pause the
video and win the game for cinderella
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on solving the
position uh
in question and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course rook captures an f7
that's just it black's only option is to
capture with the rook and this now means
that we will continue piling up on that
rook so here we have bishop the c4
black has the defender we have rook to
f8 and now the simple bishop captures on
f7 rook captures in c7 and he was in
this position on move 32 that shakhri
and mamidyarov resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
after you well there's really nothing to
do here luckily for well not luckily of
course cinderella had this in mind but
uh the the queen to have to check king
h1 and queen f1 does not result in
checkmate because after rook captures
mamidarov doesn't have rook captures on
f1 checkmate because the rook uh well is
uh unfortunately pinned so after c7 he
resigns because there's no defense this
is checkmate this is checkmate
everything is just checkmate and uh well
i'm very very happy that cinderella
played this and he showed everyone that
uh even on the highest level in the
world chess championship uh you can
employ the evan's gambit and you can
take down a former 2800 member like
shakhtar mahmoud of here
and i i i still can't believe mamadarov
declined the evans gambit yeah and you
can see he accepted it only later on 20
moves
later in the position uh where it was
much much worse for him so even if you
don't like playing the evan's gambit you
have to know how to play against it uh
and well i i think more people will
definitely uh study the events gambit uh
after more games like this are being
played and after more strong players
like mommy are taken down by using the
evans gambit uh so yeah and uh for those
of you who still haven't to do check out
my tutorial on the evans gambit it's a
very short tutorial only the basics but
it will get you nicely started if you
want to crush your opponents not like
this but you know
somewhat milder
uh so uh once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it here are the standings uh of
uh the tournament after 12 rounds uh i
told you guys that yesterday i gave you
the wrong standings so sorry about that
uh so here they are after 12 rounds uh
the leader uh levon arunyan with 10
points with this soul lead uh amin basem
uh from egypt with nine and a half then
with nine we have parham maxullu and
then a bunch of people within and half
vladimir ferrosev uh
here
the gentleman who defeated mamidyarov uh
martin kravitz
magnus crossing alexander grishok daniel
dubois
uh
arjun
nakamura uh
so those are the top 22 for the moment
but we still have nine more rounds today
so we'll see what happens uh so yeah
hope you enjoyed that uh do play the
evan's gambit it's really amazing and uh
well uh you know
that's pretty much it and i will i would
like to thank eat francos.com shirley
chong uh george julian jiglabon uh
christian hoggle and drew watkins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
amazing tournament until it ends uh
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out the evans link in the
description below see you soon